my heart aches
and a drowsy numbness pains my sense as
though of Hemlock I had drunk or emptied
some dull opiate to the drains in one
minute past leafy words head sunk his
not their envy of thy happy lot but
being too happy and nine happiness that
thou light when he had dry out of the
trees in some melodious plot of beech
and green and shadows numberless sing a
stuff summer in full throated ease o for
draught of vintage that have been cooled
a long age in the deep delve at earth
tasting of flora and the country green
dance and provincial song and sunburnt
mirth over beaker full of the warm south
full of the true the blush full
Hippocrene with be dead bubbles winking
at the brim and purples stained head
mouth that I might drink and leave the
world unseen and with thee fade away
into the forest in fade far away
dissolve and quite forget what thou
among the leaves has never known the
weariness the fever and the fret here
where men sit and hear each other groan
where palsy shakes a few sad last gray
hairs where youth grows pale and spectre
thin and dies where but to think
is to be full of sorrows and let an Ida
spares where beauty cannot keep her
lustrous eyes or new love pine at them
beyond tomorrow a way a way for I will
fly with thee not chariot advised sent
his parts but on the viewless wings of
posy though the dull brain perplexes and
retards already with the tender is the
night and haply the queen moon is on her
throne clustered around by all her
starry phase but here there is no light
say what from heaven is with the breezes
blown through verges glooms and winding
mossy waves I cannot see what flowers
are at my feet nor what soft incense
hangs upon the boughs but an embalmed
darkness guess each sweet we're with the
seasonable month and douse the grass the
thicket and the fruit tree wild white
Hawthorn in the pastoral eglantine fast
fading violets covered up in leaves and
mid maze eldest child the coming
musgroves full of dewy wine murmurous
haunt two flies on summer Eve
darkling I listen and
for many a time I have been half in love
with easeful death called him soft names
and many a music rhyme to take into the
air my quiet breath now more than ever
seems it rich to die to cease upon the
midnight with no pain while they are
pouring forth thy soul abroad in such an
ecstasy
still with us stuffs in and I have ears
in vain to thy high Requiem become Assad
that was not born for death immortal
bird no hungry generations tread the
down the same voice I hear this passing
night was heard in ancient days by
Emperor and clown
perhaps the self same song that found a
path through the sad heart of Ruth when
sick for home she stood in tears
amid the alien corn the same that oft
times have charmed magic casements
opening on the foam of perilous seas in
fairy lands forlorn
for long
the very word is like a bell to toll me
back from thee to my soul self I do the
fancy cannot cheat so well as she is
famed to do deceiving elf I do I do
by plaintive anthem fades past the near
Meadows over the still stream up the
hillside and now tis buried deep in the
next Valley glades
was it a vision or a waking dream fled
is that music
do I wake or sleep